okay wir sind live wir sind live
wahnsinniger trägt ja ok los sein dass
in den karton gelegt
[Musik]
[Applaus]
füße durchgestreckt ja ja und ich werde
jetzt davon durchschneiden
ich habe dieses kind auf die welt
gebracht hat wie man 24 stunden gedauert
ich hatte die wm des todes und jetzt
werde ich sie durchschneiden man kann
natürlich auch eine bessere schäden
größer
[Musik]
ja dieser mir ist die box hat die
sanierer selber gebastelt und es ist der
wahnsinn was sie da gemacht hat
oh mein gott ich habe einfach nur angst
ja bitte nicht zu hause nachmachen bitte
ganz wichtig
oh mein gott schneiden sie gerade durch
mein gott es sei gelegt ist
wie machen aber seien sie ehrlich ist
das mein gott die kiste hat sie wirklich
selber gebastelt den ganzen tag sie hat
nämlich gerade ferien und in den ferien
ist mehr als ein riesen ehrlich brothers
wo mein gott jetzt bin ich gespannt
du hast jetzt echt du hast ja
durchgeschnitten dieser wir wahnsinnig
wichtig für die beide durchgeschnitten
ricoh die füße wie kriegen wir die
wieder zusammen um mit gott und sie lebt
aber noch erträglich zu ende gedacht
okay ich sofort muss fotos videos und
sie jetzt legt amira
[Musik]
das ist doch irgendwie das ist irgendwie
getürkt ich glaube ihr habt einen trick
nicht ganz zu ende gedacht ist nur ne
ich aber nichts sagen oh mein gott was
ist das noch eine hose drin was macht
mein gott was machen die da drin
[Musik]
so war also ganz ganz tolles
wahnsinniges kino ich bin echt stolz auf
euch zwei die meine damen und herren
darf ich vorstellen
die ehrlich sisters die ehrlich ist das
wahnsinn
klasse ganz ganz dicken applaus bitten
[Applaus]